what's up everybody welcome back big
game spot cross kind of funny I'm Greg
Miller this is the pride of Long Island
Colin Moriarty who's been working his
balls off today you I appreciate that
that's david jaffe you never worked at
davis like I'm kidding david jaffe drawn
to death yeah one of your balls rolled
over here touch it don't know what do
you want to tell me on the air what are
you so okay here's what's fascinating so
I've listened to you for ages you guys
for ages on IGN and now on your new
stuff and when you're on yours it's I
saw conan o'brien about five years ago
when he was doing his show before it
went to TBS and he is so it's very
similar it's kind of bizarre because
when you're not on camera you're a
totally different guy now you were up
yard and your cell died down but it's
like it's like I'm the same so I'm this
here and this where I'm sitting off
stage but you you do you're Gregg so
well that when you're not Greg it's like
it's it's unsettling I don't like it I'm
sorry it's like me bozo without its may
come on that's nice I've gotta be that's
a girl that is a great reference right
don't don't beat you kind when his egos
already and fight no but I know cuz
you're you see more standard thank you
right but it's happier on camera right
beside all of his baggage he's I have
all have a lot of baggage III don't ask
you why so David yes we have you for a
long time cool when you talk about
everyone talk about where do you want to
start you want to talk about drawn to
death i'll talk about whatever you get
you know me i'll talk about whatever you
want to talk about talk about yep when
you first left you're like we're doing
the Bartlett detective agency that's
right your developer do your developer
house partially officially adopt that
was the game I thought the hell we are
we have to we do two things we do game
development and we have a division of
the company that does actual paranormal
research so okay that old but the game
people always thought oh you're doing a
haunted house game yeah and that was
never i'd love to but that was never the
case but do it I want to come on erie my
office we will oh we will will you bunny
exclusive next games haunted house game
it's called Shenmue for hahahahaha that
came scary enough as it is so what's
going on with drawn to it how's
everything coming along I think great
were you know it's fun to be here the
last time we headed out for the public
to play was at p
sex and that was really great and you
know we've done a lot of work since then
and uh whenever you put a game in front
of people it's it's you know you it's
really scary I mean it's really
terrifying are they going to like it are
they going to get it and so it's like
anything else probably with you guys
like you all these great tweets oh I
played drawn to death I loved it I loved
that I loved it that makes you feel
great and then you go to the booth and
everybody's loving it and there's one
guy who walks away half through the game
and it just breaks your [ __ ] heart
right so but it's going great I mean so
I just got here today I wasn't here
yesterday but so far people are digging
it and getting it so what's the
difference in terms of build like have
you come a long way since PSA yeah we
have I mean you know what we're really
trying to do is build a game that feels
like sort of the the child of quake and
doom with super smash brothers or power
stone right so we want to awesome yeah
so we want to build in the arena shooter
but we also want to have you know more
of a relationship between the characters
in terms of different abilities and
counters and a lot of the weapons having
multiple functions and stages and so
we've been able to build a lot more of
that into the build for today for the e3
build and we'll be launching I think
maybe around Christmas a little after a
little before we have our only announced
yet yeah but it goes right now there's
your nails look at a scoop for kind of
funny haunted house game issue as well
the reason I'm saying is because what's
fun about it is we are building it as a
service game so we are doing a slow roll
out over the summer and then starting to
see what people like and making changes
so it really I've never done a game like
that before so it's been fun so far yeah
one of the things I loved about your
presentation at PSX we were there yeah
first of all you showed it an amazing
amount of humility and we talked about
this afterwards about I love you I loved
you on stage I love you know because we
do the same thing we're nothing without
people that support us and I love that
you acknowledge that a lot of people
walk through life and never acknowledge
that you're there because people
supported you and so I love that about
you but I also loved FPS X that you were
there you talk to everyone you got you
know instruction from the gamers being
like this is this works and this doesn't
how did you compile all that information
after PSX to instruct the other your
team moving forward well so I mean I I
can't the role of a producer and video
games is really on the song I mean there
it's I can't do what I do
team can't do what they do without a
great producer and part of launching
bartlett jones was finding the right guy
or the right woman to do that and so
Nick Cannon Ellis who's producing the
game I mean the guys like [ __ ] you
know rain man with he just SAT there
with the data and just compiled it all
and figured out this means this this
means we need to do that and so yeah I
mean it was it's that balance though
right because we really want to make it
clearer to gamers that if they play
drawn to death they are getting a
curated vision we're not short order
cooks it's not like there's a lot of
freedom play games they're like make the
game with us it's like no will [ __ ]
again we I know what we want to do but
within that realm we want feedback and
we want to know hey did we miss the mark
here or is this working is this fun so
it's that balance between getting
feedback that speaks to the vision that
the team has and not going so far astray
that you're just like tell me what you
want I'll make whatever you want just by
my [ __ ] you dont rember that either but
yes sir Nick took all that data and just
we got back to the office that next
monday and it was like all right here's
the top 20 things that people I hey
let's fix those there so what was on the
list we had some camera issues you know
a lot of standard stuff while you're
dealing with a third person shooter we
had some art style issues regarding
needing things to pop better like we
love our art style but at the time it
was really hard for players to see
certain things in the level just stuff
like that nice so you said you know
you're a lot to learn yeah jumping into
this new kind of game free and all this
stuff how long did it take you to get a
grasp of it are you still going with it
we don't have a grasp of it yeah there's
the development of any game and every
time you start any project it's it's a
brand new thing so you've got to learn
that and on the side you've also got
this brand new business model and you
know i mean i've worked with sony i've
had the pleasure and privilege of being
able to work with sony for my whole
career yeah and one of the things among
many that made us want to do this with
sony versus other people we had talked
to was they wanted to do free to play
the way we wanted to do for you to play
which is you know it's set it a lot in
the press lately but it is true it's
free to play made by a team that hates
free to play so I [ __ ] hate free to
play as a designer in terms of
traditional free-to-play but what it
does is why would you want to
make why would you want to go to work
every day and make a game that basically
uh isn't it is worse than it could be
simply because you've got this meta
business model that's just constantly
bearing down on the player and it ruins
the experience so but what we loved
about free-to-play was it's like
television it's like podcasting it's
like look at all these people that will
give our game a chance that wouldn't at
a retail right so it was about going to
Sony and sitting with them and saying
here's the stuff that we want to sell
here's the stuff that we want to
monetize but here's the stuff that's
absolutely sacred which it's just we
would rather just not make the game if
we're going to have to monetize that and
Scott rody was just like [ __ ] yeah i'm
more of a paper than you are I don't
want to monetize that [ __ ] either yeah
and so it's it's so is it going to work
there's there's the noblest of
intentions it may come out though and
people pat you on the back and say great
job Jaffe for not selling power but who
knows if the game is going to work but I
think we've done yeah but you know no I
mean an end of the day there's there
have been games that have tried to be
super respectful of the player but end
of the day as much as that's there you
still have to make money you guys still
have to say you know your podcast is
sponsored by these four or five folks
and it's just it's the nature of doing
business the nice thing is you know the
good podcast if we're going to that I
don't know I'm just jumping to that but
I listen to a lot of podcasts the good
ones are the ones that are able to sort
of weave that into the conversation in a
way that it doesn't feel like you're
being marketed zoo right i love i love
WTF with marc maron yeah but I'm like
dude stop with [ __ ] 12 minutes of ads
at the front before we get to our show
look guys you want to just skip all that
not and karmically I feel terrible yeah
but I'm like dude half my drive is over
I just I'd rather you weave it in like
you guys do or like Nerdist does in the
beginning but it's quicker but you don't
show is just like dude it's 12 [ __ ]
minutes right so anyway it was tangent
but there you go so it makes sense I
think you're bringing up good points
though I think in the fact you talk
about other games have had the noblest
of intentions before or not how to work
out but I think right now is you have a
different angle on it the fact that you
are david jaffe people
no you you're a mouthpiece you're out
there you're talking you have
personality in fact I think right now as
evidenced by us and this and everything
else that is kind of funny we're lucky
enough that as us as consumers or people
who are consuming our content understand
that relationship of I really dig this
and I could get it for free but I'm one
of the one percent that wants to give
you money for it right sewing right
right absolutely no and I I think I
don't have other podcasts done the thing
where it's like you get it a little bit
later if you don't pay I didn't like we
do yeah yeah seeing that I think yeah
there's a few different ways I don't
roosterteeth windows all their stuff
like that but again that's you know uh
it makes it all loose term to the giant
things but yeah they keep ya but to your
point it's important for us that pretty
much all of our content available
eventually for you if you want that's
right exam well yeah so we have this
thing I mean one of the things that Nick
coin was sort of just the term you know
we're not doing pay for power or pay to
win but it is kind of like pay for
awesome so we are saying look you know
we've got things that are conceptually
cool that we think you're going to want
to play with and we're going to charge
for those whether it's virtual currency
or real currency but we're also we have
like a rental model and it's a rental
model that the rental price applies to
the purchase price so if we have a
weapon that's like a dollar and it's
like you know what you can rent that for
a dime for four or five games and if you
like it suddenly the price to buy it is
only 90 cents now so it's everything
everything that we can do to say look we
know what it's like to feel shitty in a
free-to-play game but we also know that
what's great about a free-to-play game
is the player base is huge and you can
always go online and find a game and so
we want to figure out a way to make sure
that both audiences are served so anyway
it's it's so when you say is this brand
new yes we're having to balance and
learn about this whole new business and
at the same time make a game which is as
hard as it's ever been it's all it's
it's never easy it's like how big is
your team right now locally in San Diego
we have about 30 game developers we have
about four people on the go side but
they don't really contribute to the game
and then we have people all over the
world that are doing a you know
outsourcing for art and things like that
so are you with the team you have now
yeah he's 30 get people are you prepared
myth that we are the better towerfall
players like you probably watered-down
your tower fall my my listen my daughter
could kick your acid oh good she managed
nine yeah so I assume I assume there's a
set up here I'm not too nice this is I
wish we brought the week only we had
that kind of course I don't like being
on a talk show and it's like Anna
Kendrick you do yodeling oh you don't
want to hear that you guys where's the
[ __ ] around all right we [ __ ] up
right sorry totally but it was just I
wanted to make sure you know that the
rivalry still burns you got to come to
San Francisco I'm ready whenever San
Francisco yeah talk about your game
whenever then play powerful absolutely
she we should have like a bet we should
have some kind of money at stake for a
charity or some sighs okay no I like
that I like that one so a lot of people
walk around the industry and and maybe
rightfully so sometimes say there's
there's a there's a vacancy of new ideas
there's just not that many new ideas
anymore writes the same annualized
shooter it's the same whatever platform
eight you know a bit platformer drawn to
death when I saw that I was like this is
one of the most novel ideas I've seen in
years cool um conceptually how did you
come up with an idea like that how do
you sell it because presumably you go to
Sony and maybe there maybe they want
something more like Killzone than
something like drawn to death but how do
you say like no actually you want this
instead I mean we had a lot of interest
and draws it out so it wasn't that I
mean you know we thought it was a strong
concept a lot of it is the budget I mean
if I would have walked in with drawn to
death and I would have said I need 80
million dollars to make this game they
would have said oh okay go [ __ ] off
right um but I mean you know you have to
be sensible about when you're bringing
something in the market that is
conceptually different or risky that you
know your budget has to sort of live in
accordance with that but you know i mean
it that was never that the concept came
for me wanting to do a dodgeball game
and I don't I don't I wanted to do this
really hyper violent dodgeball game and
I I don't draw well and so I had this
stick figure beaming this dodgeball into
this other stick figure and so I just
kind of wrote it was i was called like
hyper violent super big-headed violent
dodge but I don't know that was what was
called and from there just evolved into
this should be in on kids notebook and
this should be a shooter and this should
be this but I mean again
anybody if you're honestly saying people
walk around the industry and saying that
I I don't I don't I think that is a
that's somebody who's walking around
saying that that it has a lack of
perspective on what's actually happening
in the industry if you look at xbox at
Sony at steam the amount of creativity
and fresh ideas are all over the place I
mean they're everywhere to be seen and
thats i don't i don't believe that it's
not i think there was a time when you
could say that about the industry i
don't think we're there anymore yeah i
agree i agree with you in the sense that
you just have to look a little harder
sometimes but that's basically i mean
it's just the unfortunate nature of some
people just disparage a downloadable
game or a ten-dollar game i think every
game has to cost sixty dollars and if
you want to be in that realm then maybe
you are gonna find a lack of diversity
but oh it's the pros yeah i know but
yeah when you're ignoring all the Indies
when you're ignoring what i feel like
everybody's things I mean again I mean I
you know if you let me again this is why
it's always that I get that question
sometimes and again my career so far I'm
grateful to say has been with Sony when
you are swimming in that DNA I mean look
at the horizon last guardian um you got
this new game got a war three yeah okay
well right okay but I mean dreams I mean
it you know I just I it's never been
part of going into a meeting with Alan
Becker or Scott rody or Shuhei and it's
like no I want a military shooter but i
always say shoe a when he heard me pitch
god of war which you think well that's
kind of a slam dunk he's just like
what's innovative about this like oh and
i had to pitch him on it right but if
you if you go into roadies office and
you pitch him call a duty he'd be like
well they already made call of duty so I
I that hasn't been my experience getting
to work with Sony that they're looking
for just make us the next thing and I
think that bears out if you look at the
library of games year after year from
that company and sometimes they get they
get the [ __ ] kicked out of them
commercially because some of this stuff
doesn't sell it but they still keep
making it and thank God I was gonna say
that's that's important right like we
had Peter more on here and he's talking
about their the new game
with the yarn uh yeah great it's like
it's not gonna make money it's gonna be
a wall that's coming from EA oh my god
what happened that was that man yeah
that's the beautiful thing is he was he
was really done earth saying like listen
we make all this money on FIFA will just
take will break even on this if we can
and write like it's our duty to bring
this game out and maybe you know maybe
there's a little spin their right and of
course they want to make money on it um
and I bet it will make money i can't
imagine that that was budgeted at such a
level then they have to sell a million
units to break even um but yeah I don't
even know if it's a that when I look
maybe I'm responding in this way because
when I look at that game it doesn't feel
like it's a duty it feels like that's a
work of love right it feels like that's
a word from someone who really are a
team that really wanted to express that
and it's charming and it's very cool and
so I just I love it I that's one of my
favorite things I've seen so far you
know from the press conferences as that
game yeah absolutely what's up is that
my cup I don't I only guys Mike Stephen
up Kevin bring up mix microphone he's
got the oh [ __ ] Mike give me something
low where you gonna call right up come
into the frame I'm gonna come in right
here we need one year we have a boy band
you know Nick's car you know we've met a
couple to a couple times yeah now but
have you met him since he's an Internet
superstar twice over I haven't that I
probably know when he was still
respectful and I don't cry oh yeah you
are a very shy man david jaffe as you
know we are quickly blowing up because
of that we want to give out awards for
the games that we like yeah um now I
just went over and played your game oh
great when I liked it a lot I'm sure
what it reminds me of not paying
attention in Spanish class that's
exactly what we were talking and I
really like that so I'd like to give you
the first of my kind of funny approve
Awards cool live can we put that on the
booth double-sided tape on the back of
it there you go oh I want to walk around
with us on my shoulder most the day a
little conversation about things they
can hear shirt for all the rest of your
interviews that's great what am I chain
free if you wanna wear it like Cisco
absolutely yeah he was here yesterday I
did I've always excited about what
celebrities are like gonna come to the
booth
you know yeah it was a fun one yes was
he the biggest one people saw yesterday
Spielberg comes every year and I have
never been around when he's played any
game I've worked on but I would just be
like oh my [ __ ] god JJ Abrams comes
through usually with his son to that
would be cool yeah that would be very
cool uh yeah Cisco was big you'd big
yesterday he was I know soulja boy was
floating around playing game but ok but
Cisco and soldier boy they haven't
really had since go wait out in a while
hey Cisco's gone indie like we did oh
good we still making sure you so bad he
just came back from China ok enough
money to fly here on his own dog on our
stupid show so yeah he's doing pretty
what school tomorrow we have devon Sawa
though so there who that is idle hands
final destination Nikita right grant
Akita and brandy Robb you I don't know
oh okay there you go hey did you see the
trailer for EM Knights new movie the
grandma movie uh-huh oh my [ __ ] god
have you as anybody seen this nobody
knows all about to tell the crowd heaven
pull a private money here about out
because it's so creepy it's further off
its Shyamalan and you never know what
you're gonna get a twist well maybe not
always but it's just just just [ __ ]
go to the trailer it is got free pious
thing and we can't actually go to the
toilet no I mean your wife go watch it
watch it but there are not that worth
your life I'm gonna go give us these out
okay yes is great thank you very much
here thanks for coming on the show yeah
yeah I got over here I'm gonna cut some
eye holes in it I'll just get cheap
please like that you know where we have
it hella with your family today be me
for a few seconds to wrap it up okay you
can show off the next 15 seconds if we
wrap it up he's nice Jaffe we love you
you have really damn resist I would love
to you're welcome with us any time so
thank you very much dude we're doing
that I like what you're doing do you
like being off IGN that's what I want to
know yeah yeah we're good it was great
yeah when I chin was awesome to us for
eight years yeah no I don't amazing oh
yeah we're very honored by the sport we
got from everyone and thank you so much
for listening Austin sporting of every
week every way can i drive to work it's
wonderful drawn to death yep it's coming
out Christmas ish maybe yeah kind of
david jaffe
you